it's a very fundamental question for
humanity to ask
where do we come from and we are we are
in some sense
a trying to study that and b trying to
educate everyone
about that today on chalk radio
we're talking star stuff in this episode
we're going to be exploring stellar
archaeology
and the origins of well
everything it all comes from
the cosmos from from the stars and from
the supernova explosions
our guest today is associate professor
of physics anna freebo
in a series of short videos created to
go with her book
searching for the oldest stars she
reveals the secrets of
stardust and explains the cosmic origins
of the elements
hello my name is anna frevo i'm a
physics professor at mit
but i'm actually an astronomer so i sit
in the astrophysics division and i
search for the oldest stars in the
universe and it's pretty cool and i
think we're going to talk a lot more
about that
it is pretty cool and what's even cooler
is that by the end of this podcast
you'll understand what she does
even if your prior experience with
astronomy like mine
starts and ends with gazing at the stars
and saying
wait is that the big dipper and that's
exactly why we wanted to
have her on this show she's an expert
science communicator
she conveys complex topics in inspiring
and clear ways
as the title of her book suggests much
of professor friebel's work is rooted in
learning more about the origins
of the elements by studying the oldest
stars in the universe
i was curious how old we were talking
about
we want to figure out exactly how
element formation proceeds
and you have to look at different types
of objects in the cosmos to figure it
out because all the elements are made
there
now if you take the sun for example
the sun is about 4.6 billion years old
and the universe is about 13.8 billion
years old
so the sun and its content
reflects the state of the universe 4.5
or 4.6
billion years ago now um that's pretty
cool
that we get this kind of information but
it actually it's much better for us to
look at stars
that are much older that are formed
sooner
uh after the big bang and that's why we
look at the oldest stars
by studying the composition of these
stars we can then
figure out what produced all these
elements that we're seeing in the stars
this process of looking to the oldest
stars for information about the building
blocks of the universe
is called stellar archaeology and it
helps us look into the past
way into the past we are
archaeologists of sorts right we are
really good in
piecing together the past because every
distant object whose light we're seeing
has traveled sometime
to us and we are now seeing it as when
you know for example a galaxy was in its
baby stage we're seeing that now so that
lets us
explore the past now these stars that
we're exploring
are in the milky way and that's
really our local cosmic neighborhood
the light travel time within our galaxy
is thousands of years perhaps
at least to the stars that we're looking
at so compared to the age of the
universe
that's next to nothing so we are not
looking for stars
that are very distant and whose light
has traveled to us for
literally a zillion years we are looking
for stars that are truly old and still
sitting there and again by studying
their composition
we can then learn what the
universe look like at the time of their
formation soon after the big bang
[Music]
you might be wondering how a scientist
does this sort of work
this stellar archaeology digging into
the farthest reaches of the universe
you'd have to use some of the best
telescopes in the world and it's
definitely not something you could set
up in your backyard
you have to fly to south america to
chile
because most of the big telescopes are
located there others are located in
hawaii
and while this sounds like a vacation
it's really anything but
so you usually fly through miami or
atlanta and then you have to
get to santiago de chile the capital of
chile and then you have to fly another
hour from there to la serena and then
you get picked up
by a car and drives you the two and a
half hours up into the mountain
and you get there and you see the
glittering
telescope domes on the horizon waiting
for you
and then it's like a tiny tiny little
village up there so there are
guest rooms for the observers where you
sleep during the day
so thick curtains are a must and uh well
so you get there
you you meet other observers from from
the other telescopes
you have your dinner and then you go to
the telescope
and then you sit there with lots of
monitors and you work together with the
telescope operator
they operate the actual telescope and
the dome
and make sure that you know you don't
break anything
and then the astronomer operates the
instrument
so that's basically the a giant digital
phone camera or a spectrograph that you
know it's like a prism
where you split the light into rainbow
colors so you have
your buttons to press and decisions to
make and of course a whole strategy
about what to observe
and how to spread things out over the
entire night so that you use
every single second of telescope 10 that
you have because it's
it's expensive and never enough
telescope time
and then you know you get tired but you
keep going and you get even more tired
and you
keep going until the sun literally comes
up again and at that point
in the sun rise you just go
back to bed and then sleep as much as
you can during the day and then history
repeats itself
but if the weather is bad and let's say
there are clouds or it rains or it snows
or something else then tough luck
you go home empty-handed
now when professor freebull is at the
telescope down in chile
she's getting a very different
perspective than when she's back here in
cambridge massachusetts
because the universe you can visualize
is different depending on where you're
observing from
we have a different night sky in the
northern in the southern hemisphere
and that's because of our orientation in
the galaxy
we live in a spiral galaxy and so what
we see as the
milky way in quotes on the night sky is
actually the next door spiral arm
and so that's why we have a band now in
the northern hemisphere we're looking
at the spiral arm that's kind of
behind us so we're looking outside of
the galaxy
so looking out in the southern
hemisphere we're looking
in so it's really bright and shiny
and that backlights the spiral arm and
so when you're in the southern
hemisphere you see a beautiful
bright band over the sky much
unlike what we have in the northern
hemisphere it's truly remarkable
how bright this can be
so there's time during a single exposure
to sneak out and look at the sky
because i'm still a person i'm not just
a scientist
and i do like looking at the at the sky
and so
i have been just walking outside with my
flashlight under
under the milky way and uh you can
actually switch off your
your flashlight there and just walk
in the light of the milky way you know
no moon just
starlight you can you can totally find
your way around
[Music]
i was curious to learn more about how
professor freebolt went from stargazing
with the rest of us
to stellar archaeology what made her
want to dig
so much deeper into our cosmos
it's just always been with me ever since
i was little
i i knew i wanted to work with
with stars and i knew it wasn't planets
and it wasn't galaxies it was stars
and i can really only describe what
draws me
to this and always has is the analogy to
you know why is blue your favorite color
why is it not red
that's just more it's more like a
feeling and it really hit me when i
learned about old stars
i did not know about old stars
specifically until i was
22 but uh
in australia i i first encountered old
stars and i knew that that's
it for the rest of my life
[Laughter]
[Music]
as i shared earlier professor friebel is
the author of the book
searching for the oldest stars which
makes this extremely
complex topic accessible to anyone still
retaining some of that childlike wonder
and curiosity about the world around
or rather above all of us
these times really speak for themselves
people need to have more
scientific literacy and i think the
forgotten
point is that so much wonder comes along
with it right
information is power but it's also
wonder
and i think it's really really important
as a scientist to
make your work accessible you don't need
a bachelor's in science to
to understand that you know your body is
made of different things
and you know we always ask the question
where does stuff come from
where does the money in my wallet come
from that's what my five-year-old is
asking now right so
yeah from my bank account but you know
the story is obviously
a lot bigger and and science is exactly
the same thing right i mean i could talk
to him about the economy and
the stock market and make it like really
really complicated but in the end is you
know i have a job and it pays
and that's the basic idea and coming
actually coming back to the stellar
archaeology concept i think
everyone should really know what their
ancestry is like
and we are doing the exact same thing in
the cosmos right we're looking at
stellar generations and what came before
and it's a very fundamental question for
humanity to ask
where do we come from
part of professor freeple's approach
involves pulling back the curtain
on what astrophysicists actually do on a
day-to-day basis
and this is something she feels pretty
passionate about
the nobel prize was one for this in this
discovery
that's cool that's very impressive but
is that the really the interesting bit i
think for many people it's actually much
more interesting to
hear the journey about what went all
wrong on that path
to success we like to just take the
success in the end and throw away the 99
other percent but that's not what life
and reality is like
as i said we go to the telescope and
it's cloudy
right but once i found something
i made a big discovery then everyone
literally forgets
how many struggles you you had getting
there
it's great to have success but
most of life is it's not success
it's it's hard work and it's facing the
struggles
and i think reminding people that even
when you do have success there's really
much much more to the story
professor friebel's videos on mit open
courseware
are meant for anyone to learn from
regardless of previous physics or
astronomy knowledge
it's really for anyone and the book is
written in the same way if you don't
like a chapter
you can just go to the next chapter you
could even read the chapters backwards
um it's all set up so it's completely
interchangeable and flexible
i think that you know children age
10 or 15 could probably start watching
this
because again it's about the big
questions
if you don't understand the sentence or
the detail man don't worry about it
right you wanna wonder and be amazed
by something it's perfectly fine not to
understand
the details because it's not the details
that make you amazed
it's it's catching a glimpse of
something bigger
where you develop the desire to
understand more
and once you want to understand more my
details are a drop in the ocean
in parting i wanted to go from looking
to the past to looking to the future
what exciting things are scientists
doing to pave the way for more discovery
and to inspire joy and wonder for
generations to come
what i foresee in the next
five to ten years is that this
combination of
knowing more about how the elements are
all created
and on what time scales finding of
course additional old stars in that
all ages using their motions on the sky
and then combining that with large
simulations for the formation of the
milky way
and so i think there's going to be a lot
of work
into really figuring out
all the puzzle pieces that
it put together make up the mickey way
and we figured out a few big ones but
there are still lots of little
details that that that we need to figure
out and and i think that
that's going to be the big thing so the
milky way in the bigger view
in a more holistic view that's that's
going to be the focus
in the next 10 years
ultimately with the help of educators
like professor friebel
astrophysics can be a way to become more
interested in the world
an avenue for understanding our place in
the much much larger
scheme of things if you're ready to
learn more about the cosmic origin of
the elements
or have students who would be inspired
by stellar archaeology
you can find professor friebel's videos
on our mit opencourseware website
our resources are always free and
remixable so they're perfect for use in
your own teaching
for nearly 20 years open courseware has
worked to share some of the best
resources from mit
with teachers and learners just like you
from newer resources like this podcast
to our ever-growing library of online
course content
a gift to ocw helps us do so freely and
openly
if you're able please consider
supporting ocw with a donation
at ocw.mit.edu
thank you for listening i'm sarah hansen
from mit open courseware
signing off from under the night skies
over cambridge massachusetts
mom pass the car